[Music]
good evening I'm Alexander Rosen the
executive director here at long now so
glad to have a full house I think I
think the topic tonight is on
everybody's mind just a couple quick
notes as many of you know we have a
podcast of this series that podcast has
been going on since a few years after
the series started in 2003 and those of
you who have been waiting for it to be
on the Google Play Store for the last 14
years now you can get it there just so
you know but that's actually one of the
largest outreaches that long now has
about a million people a year been
downloading the audio of these talks and
so it's it's it's always great to find
somebody who has heard about this series
out in the world and actually barely
knows what long now does but this is
kind of the way that that a lot of
people figure out about the rest of the
series other projects and general
projects around long-term thinking
hi I'm Stuart brand from long now
getting into the pace of government at
its details level at the user interface
of government with citizens with
customers is such an interesting place
that I'm not sure that we all give it
enough time and that's why it's so
useful tonight they have a government
user interface expert with a bunch of
experience to come and talk about that
Jennifer pahlka
I have been to many long now seminars so
it's it's really an honor to be on the
stage thank you and in fact I was at the
last one where Steven Johnson talked
about how when technologies are just
emerging there in that that space of
delight and play and invention and
discovery and then they become
commercialized and they get a little bit
bit more boring and what I'm gonna do is
pick it up way after that when these
technologies have gotten in some ways so
boring that maybe hopefully they're
interesting again but we are going to
spend some time with something I think
people don't talk about a lot and that's
what's wrong with government how to have
some ideas about how to fix it but more
importantly I think what I hope you take
away from tonight is is sort of a fresh
view on what fixing government might
really mean and I want to start with a
short story actually I'm not kidding it
really is a short story that my friend
Matthew Weaver wrote a minute I've
abridged it a little bit here and I have
to use this because it uses so many
acronyms that I don't even know that
it's gonna curl your hair but I trust me
they're technical acronyms or government
acronyms but I think you'll get it
Matt Weaver was a Google engineer who we
brought to the White House for the
healthcare.gov rescue effort and decided
to stay in as a member of the United
States digital service and then a member
of the Defense digital service and he
knows a lot about this and was inspired
to write a short story about technology
policy in government so our story begins
with a troubled technology project at
the Air Force and a part of this project
is a suite of software one of the
components in that suite is a scientific
calculation that relies on time
sensitive data collected by distributed
measurement stations the job of this
software is to get the data from the
stations to the software that does the
calculation the measurement stations
send the data using something called
multicast user
datagram protocol first acronym alert
multicast UDP is a basic feature of the
internet protocol since 1989 it's part
of the Internet code in almost every
operating system in the world it costs
no money every server operating system
includes tools to check and debug
multicast UDP so sending the data
through UDP would be fast reliable easy
it's a little bit like if you wanted to
put a nail on a board you might do this
that's how it should work unfortunately
that's not what happens in this piece of
software that the Air Force has
commissioned instead it's a little bit
more like this so first a piece of
software subscribes to the multicast UDP
messages it reads the data as it arrives
it checks the cryptographic signatures
in each Datagram then it recode the data
into a format called XML SDC with
another cryptographic signature XML SCC
has a lot of overhead so this stuff uses
memory and a CPU time it makes the
message larger then the software uses a
protocol called soap to put the XML SEC
message on to something called an
Enterprise Service bus XML LSCC
ESB and soap are all very complicated in
fact they come in a lot of incompatible
versions they cost a lot of money ESB
for example is an entire suite of
software in itself so checking and
debugging this software also needs
special tools and more specialized
programming experience these Kools tools
don't come as a part of any operating
system by default oh it's not even over
yet so the ESB eventually delivers the
new XML SCC message with the monitoring
data - yet another piece of software and
this software uses soap to retrieve the
XML SCC from the SCP copies and memory
parses out to the original data blah
blah blah finally the piece of software
copies the data into a shared segmented
memory where the calculation software
can access it so you're probably hating
government contractors right now you're
probably thinking oh my god they're
wasting taxpayer dollars why would you
do it that way well I'm not a
defender of government contractors been
my experience it's a lot more
complicated than this and what Weaver
did was asked the contractor why they
built this whole big Rube Goldberg
machine instead of just hammering the
nail into the board and the contractor
said the customer made us do it
so Weaver looked and this was true the
request proposal from the Air Force
requires solutions that use been clued
in ESP that enterprise service bus now
why did the Air Force want all this
complex costly technology the author
asked the Air Force the Air Force said
the the Defense Department made it to do
it so the author looked and this was
true the DoD issued guidance as recently
as 2010 that requires that all
technology acquisitions be service
oriented architectures that comply with
information Enterprise Architecture so
why did the Department of fence require
this complex dependency multiplying
technology in all of its systems the
author asked the DoD and the DoD said
the Office of Management and Budget made
us do it so the officer looked and this
was also true as recently as 2008 OMB
issued guidance and requirements that
require all federal IT projects to have
a service-oriented architecture and the
rules for SOA require an sob an EF ESB
excuse me maybe that too
so why did the Office of Management and
Budget do it
they said the chief information officers
counsel Brooke made us do it
the author looked up this this was also
true as far back as 1999 the federal CIO
Council deployed the federal enterprise
architecture 5 that requires federal
technology ceilings of any kind to
include an ESB by way of SOA guidance so
why would the CIO Council do this again
the author asked the CIO Council the CIO
Council said Congress made its do it
this is also true there are several
pieces of legislation that instruct the
CIOs to issue this guidance there are
two key ones the 1993 government
performance act and the 1996 cleaner
Cohen act I always loved talking about
the cleaner Cullen act because I always
think it's written by player from mash
and Leonard Cohen and sadly is not
instead it is a piece of software that
if you google it it tells you before
you're even finished writing the word
that you're looking for a compliance
checklist which generally means you're
in sort of a key territory on but
together these two laws require that the
Office of the President issue a plan for
all technology so let's be clear an ESB
is not necessarily like a terrible thing
to include if you look it up in
Wikipedia it actually tells you that ESB
promotes agility and flexibility with
regard to high protocol level
communications between applications that
can't be a bad thing right so these CIOs
were not being idiots they weren't
trying to ensure that all federal IT
projects become massive predictable
failures for 20 years unfortunately
that's sort of what happened and the
moral of this story as Weaver puts it
and this is the end of his story almost
all outcomes generated by technical
policy will be unintended consequences
so I have worked this intersection of
technology and government now for about
six years and I have had literally
dozens of people come up to me and say
well you're
smart about this so what's the law we
could pass why can't we just pass a law
that repeals that or writes this thing
or over does this and so I think that
that's a great question but I have come
to think of it as the Deathstar of
thinking it's basically the notion that
if we just place one very well-placed
shot in the thermal exhaust port of the
Death Star then the entire apparatus of
our of our oppression is just gonna go
boom into the sky and we're suddenly
going to be free and people think that
because this is government that shot is
a very very well written law better than
all the laws that we've written so far
and the problem is that we just don't
yet know how to write laws that aren't
subject to that bigger law that law of
unintended consequences and so what I
want to talk about are some of the
people who are dealing with those laws
the law of unintended consequences and
also the actual laws like clinger-cohen
when I was in the White House in 1980
excuse me 2013 and 14 I helped stand up
a unit called the United States digital
service it's the thing that my friend
Mint Weaver moved into and the idea
there was that we needed really great
technology people to come work on the
president's top priorities here's some
of the people who came to work for the
United States digital service they're
fantastic people they mostly just like
Code for America fellows where I work
have experience in the consumer internet
so there used to on a daily basis making
apps interfaces that work great for
users that think people think that
people want to use which is why we
wanted to bring them into government so
I'm gonna talk about some of their
experiences in the front here to the
left is a guy in a green shirt that's
Brian Leffler he happens to be talking
to Marina Martin and for some reason I'm
gonna reference both of those people in
my talk because they're both friends a
mister with marina marina has been the
until very recently the chief technology
the sir at the Veterans Administration
and that's a really hard job she's done
some amazing stuff here's a project that
she did she noticed that very few people
are able to apply for health benefits
online veterans are able to apply for
health benefits and what happened really
was that technically you could apply
online if you had the exact right
combination of Internet Explorer and
Adobe Reader on your computer so if you
didn't have that exact version of ie and
that exact version of Adobe you get this
error message and I think what happened
is that either people just didn't check
because the somebody had verified that
the contract was done the the contractor
had done it and they've gotten the check
mark or people tried it happen to have
that exact combination which is not
totally unthinkable given the technology
that the VA runs or they just didn't
check but basically she started clay
needed people that veterans were not
able to apply online and the answer that
she got from folks was something about
like this this is a very quick clip from
30 rock
[Applause]
[Music]
so so Maria actually finally went out
her team went out into the street and
I'm not making this up
found homeless veterans and asked them
to try to apply online in fact found one
who had tried to apply 20 times online
in 20 times seen that error message did
screen capture of them trying to use it
brought them to the deputy secretary and
got the approval to do a better
application form online vets gov is
pretty simple a basic web form that
allows you to apply online and it works
it just works and this is the kind of
work that that team has been doing and
they've been doing dozens and dozens of
projects like that all over government
not just at the VA digital service but
in the other branches of the u.s.
digital service and the other eight
cabinet agencies that have those teams
so these guys are doing amazing work for
the American people and you might think
that if they have enemy that it's the
kind of people who say your ceiling
isn't leaking and I fact I think that
they and this is the experience at USDA
Senate Code for America as well the they
find that the partners that they work
with in government are in fact wonderful
kind caring creative people who want to
get the job done right and if they have
any enemies it's it's the laws one of
the biggest enemies of the people who
work in technology and government is the
paperwork reduction Act of 1980 and we
always refer to it as the comically miss
named paperwork reduction act of 1980
because it somehow makes entirely
enormous Lea more amounts of paperwork
it basically is a law that says if you
want to put anything out to the public
that will collect information back to
the government you have to go through a
process of getting your form approved
that is a minimum of six months
including all these waiting periods it
all has to go through one office the
Office of Information and regulatory
affairs o IRA which is terribly
understaffed and so it makes a lot more
paperwork for bureaucrats and maybe you
don't think that's a
the problem for the American public is
it makes it almost impossible to publish
a really good web application or web
form that you might want to use so let
me explain a little bit I'm going to
show you a web form that I think is very
good of course we made it at Code for
America I'm sorry this is oh I read
numbers when you paperwork reduction Act
is why there's a number up in the corner
of your tax form the OMB number by the
2016 and then you'll notice that at the
bottom that there's an they're telling
you that there's an entire separate set
of instructions having to do with the
paperwork reduction Act so we're already
in funky territory but let me show you a
web form that I think works really well
Code for America team made this
application for Californians to apply
for food assistance nationally it's
known as snap we call it CalFresh here
our app is called get CalFresh and if
you look at the the questions you'll see
that the wording is very easy to
understand
you know what you're being asked and the
questions it takes about eight minutes
to apply for food assistance in
California using this form and maybe it
doesn't seem like rocket science to you
but it's much better than than what you
would what i'ma show you in a minute and
the point is that this is result of
thousands and thousands of iterations we
put this out to users and then we
watched what they did and if someone was
confused by a question we changed it we
changed the language we change the
design we've changed which questions we
asked so that we make the time required
to follow form as short as possible but
the completion of the form knowing the
questions that we need to get from our
users in order to make sure that they
get a successful application when they
apply to the state we need to get those
questions right so this is an enormous
number of iterations now think about if
every single iteration of that form had
to go through the six month process at
OMB it simply wouldn't work and when you
have applications that do have to go
through that you get something like this
this is how you apply for food stamps in
California now if you haven't found to
get CalFresh please spread the word
about get CalFresh it takes 40 leave
45 minutes to apply it asks 200 and
something questions you can't save your
work it doesn't work on a mobile phone
most people who start it don't ever
finish it and this is the result not
just of the paperwork reduction act it's
the result of a way of thinking that
says we must ask every possible question
when we have this user in front of us
because we're never gonna get a chance
to do it again um so this is an example
of what I like to call the outside-in
strategy we created this form
independent of government we it
certainly complies with all everything
that's needed we very successfully get
food stamps for thousands of people
through that form but because we can
work at our own pace and we are not
subject to we are subject to many many
different regulations and we comply with
them in our own manner but we decide on
how we're going to comply with them
which means that we can move at a pace
much faster than the pace of government
while still really you know really
working with government and one of the
things I want to want to understand is
this is not an outside strategy it's an
outside in strategy and what do I mean
by that when we started this form we
thought great if we can make it easier
for people to apply then more people
will be able to get food assistance and
that's important
California is the second worst state in
the nation in terms of participation by
eligible people in snap we have more
people by far who are eligible for this
program that aren't on it and it's not
as many people think because we're
trying to keep people off the program so
when we put up this form we thought
great now now of the problem will be
solved but let's just check let's follow
up with our users by text message and
ask them if if they've if they got got
the benefit so we started texting all
our users and we found things like this
this is actually from one of our own
staff you get a letter telling you when
your interview is going to be the
interview is a required step to get the
benefit this is Jake's letter he does
not speak Chinese
we found and this is more statistically
that in certain counties double-digit
percentages of the people who applied
got the letter telling them when their
interview is after the date of the
interview and when you don't get the
interview you start over at the
beginning in another County everybody
that we texted said I got this fraud
prevention program form and I read the
questions and they're really
intimidating I don't know how to answer
them and I'm afraid to answer them and
so I'm not returning the form and then
you don't progress so our team as we do
called the county welfare director and
said very respectfully you know this
form is not required by any law policy
or regulation and she said we don't send
that form out and two weeks later she
called us back and she said thank you so
much for letting us know I didn't know
that the eligibility workers were
sending the format now I've talked to
them they're not doing it anymore and
suddenly we see in our data that more
and more of those people are getting
through the system so the point of this
is not that we are sitting outside
government but that we're actually
increasingly deeply embedded in the
operations of government in order to get
better outcomes a nicer web form is a
lovely thing but actually getting
somebody on the program makes a lot more
difference to us so this is sort of the
pattern that we follow our model we
build an alternate app as fast as we can
get it as good as we can we collect data
from users about what's going on we use
that to help government agencies debug
their operations and that very often
leads to changes in policy I'm gonna
talk about policy later on in the talk
that in turn builds trust because the
agencies appreciate what we're doing and
that gives us the leverage then to build
another app like our clear my record app
which is for people to take low-level
old felonies off their records so that
they can be eligible for jobs housing
and other benefits
we also run an inside-out play in fact
that's what we started doing by which I
mean putting great people in government
we started doing this in
our first fellowship year in 2011 where
we got folks from the tech industry to
go work in City Hall this is max Ogden
he was one of our first fellows and I
put him up there because I just talked a
little bit about goodwill with people in
government and Max had this very long
beard and for some reason that beard
became a way of really connecting with
people in Boston City Hall because the
word got around that if you had data
problems and everybody had data problems
go find the guy with the beard so these
guys went into government I'm gonna show
you one project that they did that's not
Max's Joe Mahoney did this the mayor
asked us to work about midway through
the year on a project around school
selection they had changed the rules
about how kids with how kids get
assigned to public schools and the way
they were communicating it to parents
was a 28 page printed brochure with
six-point type but the problem is it
didn't tell you where your kid could go
because it was a mapping problem it was
about the distance from your house and a
couple of other factors to the school
and so Joel and with a little bit of
help from another fellow went off for
about ten weeks and put up this basic
web application called discover BPS
where you could type in the your name
age your your address age of your kid
whether there was a sibling in the
public schools and it returned a mapped
list of which schools your your kid
could attend and again if this doesn't
seem like rocket science it isn't but
the point of this is that at the end of
this project we were told that this
10-week project with one and a half
full-time employees on it that if it had
gone through regular channels it would
have taken about two years and cost
about two million dollars which takes
brings me to the word that I can't
believe I've made it this far without
saying which is procurement procurement
is sort of the dirty word in circles of
people who deal with government
technology all it really is is the rules
that are supposed to govern how the
government eyes things including
technology I've always been interested
in how we ended up with this particular
set of rules
and so I was intrigued recently when
Brian the guy from the photo before who
is at the United States digital service
had posted this on Facebook he said he
was struck by the realization that many
of the systems which plagued us now were
created by a tiny group of
well-intentioned good government
congressmen in the 70s and 80s and he
goes on to say those mechanisms were
left to sit for 30 to 40 years and
surprise now they suck his opinion but
this Jack Brooks character that he
referenced was very interesting to me
and I went and I looked him up and it
turns out he's a fascinating guy so he
is a was a Democrat from Beaumont Texas
he was in the Congress for 42 years
he was in the motorcade when JFK was
shot he was on Air Force One by LBJ side
when he was sworn in that's him right
there behind Jackie O he was also one of
the one of the very few southern
lawmakers who refused to sign the
southern manifesto against integrating
schools he's really fascinating guy so
this is a picture of him working and
turns out a lot of the work that this
guy did was around procurement he in
later in his career was a congressman
who introduced the paperwork reduction
Act he also created the office of
federal procurement policy where I spent
a lot of my time when I worked at the
White House it's a it's a fascinating
place so he's known for a couple of
things called the Brooks Act there was
the Brooks Act of 1965 which is really
about the fact that he was looking
across federal government where we were
starting to do enormous amounts of
automated data processing and he said
hey if we pull all that together and
centralize it we could get a much lower
price and it could be more standardized
we could do a much better job of data
processing across the federal government
and so he wrote this act to do that but
if you google Brooks Act you're actually
going to come up with the Brooks Act of
1972
actually had a very opposite intention
this was an act that he wrote when he
realized that going for lowest price
when you were hiring an engineering or
architecture firm ends up in buildings
that fall down on you so he wrote
legislation that made competency
qualifications and experience the
criteria for choosing those kinds of
firms and services for the federal
government
I love Ulta this is associated with him
it's a quote from Ronald Reagan at a
ceremony recognizing design excellence
in federal buildings apparently inspired
by Jack Brooks he said good design
doesn't cost money
good design saves money and you know
that warms my heart so we know what
warms Reagan's heart Jack Brooks ran
into this guy and I think it's 1984 he's
also from Congress his name's Berkley
Bedell he is from Iowa he was only in
Congress for 12 years I don't think he
had quite the standing and reputation
that Jack Brooks did but he is the guy
you've probably never heard his name but
you probably heard this story he went
and found this kit of sort of basic
hardware that the Air Force had bought
it had 21 items in it the total that the
Air Force had paid for it was ten
thousand one hundred and sixty eight
dollars and 56 cents he went to his
hardware store and bought the same 21
items for $92 and 44 cents and he
brought them to the floor of Congress
and introduced an amendment to the
military spending authorization bill
designed to promote more vigorous
competition and lower prices but most
famously he brought this hammer into
Congress and kind of ranted about the
cost of this hammer
now who fought him on this amendment
jack brooks jack brooks and fred in fact
said this threatens to disrupt the
legitimate procurement activities of the
defense department he said this
amendment while seeking to cure the
illness may kill the patient so he had a
different view of this which i thought
was really interesting Buerkle Bedell
did not
succeed in his amendment it passed the
house I think it failed in the Senate
but I think most of many of you have
heard about this hammer it sort of lived
on in lore it's sometimes known as the
$400 hammer or the $600 hammer the $800
hammer because people exaggerate things
over time but it also became the
centerpiece of Al Gore's well not be
centerpiece it became a player in Al
Gore's reinventing government which he
did when he became vice president in
1983 part of his thing was to say he's
gonna go around giving awards to people
in government who were saving government
money and the award literally is this
cheap frame a $6 hammer and this printed
thing and the ribbon that was like the
whole idea of the war was it was cheap
which is super cute in fact um on the
right there the end of the
black-and-white photo he's giving it to
the deputy secretary of defense for the
defense travel system the guy he's
giving it to his name is hammer II so
just like my oh there's so many hammers
hammers hammers I thought that was
interesting they gave it to the defense
travel system because now we have a
branch of the United States digital
service called the defense digital
service a fantastic team of developers
of which Matt Weaver was one and they
went around trying to choose like which
are the most horrible projects horrible
things in DoD that they could fix and
the first thing they chose was the
defense droppable system apparently it
takes hours and hours to book a ticket
and many more hours to file your
expenses and it's the thing that people
at the DoD complain the most about if
anyone hears from DoD you'll have to
tell me if that's true
so either that thing in 1997 with hammer
II was not that good to start with or
it's just not aged well but uh but back
to Vidal why did Brooks fight him on
this well I think Vidal was basically
fighting to keep prices low by imposing
rules and you know that's the amendment
didn't pass but that idea that if we
write enough rules government
procurement will work better it is
essentially how it works today you know
the Federal Acquisition regulation is
the thing
many other things but the Federal
Acquisition regulation is basically 775
pages of rules that tell you how to do
this
one part of procurement is the request
for proposal or the RFP here is one
visualization from it of it from one one
you know interpretation of it and within
that is step three only one of many and
it says for IT procurements the
department prepares and submits and IIT
procurement requisition to IT with
specifications that step alone takes
many years it's actually very uncommon
to be able to do that in less than a
year or even or less than a couple of
years because you have to tell somebody
absolutely everything that the software
is going to do and how it's going to do
it before you ever write a line of code
before you ever talk to a vendor about
it so that's like how this was built for
instance taxpayers paid eight hundred
million dollars to build this I'm not
making this up
we pay eighty million dollars a year to
maintain this piece of software in the
state of California it's only it's one
of only three different systems that you
it's one of three different systems that
you could use to sign up for food stamps
in California
that's not how good software is built we
believe that good software is built in a
user centered iterative data-driven
fashion learn build measure and this may
sound familiar to many of you the truth
is though that we are starting to be
able to build government software in
this fashion and not just the little
things thank you yes
[Applause]
it's not just the little apps that you
could do like Joel did with the
discovered bps I'm gonna tell you a
quick story about a procurement that we
got involved with last year and I should
say coach Berg does not do procurement
Consulting's is not indicative of our
business but about a year and a half ago
when we were working with the state on
the food stamps stuff they asked us to
look at a procurement for child welfare
child welfare system it looks something
like this
and we took a look at it it assumed that
the price tag would start at about six
hundred million dollars and that it
would take about six years to build and
long story short we said this not
probably gonna work and made some
suggestions for how they might might do
it differently and then about six months
later found out that they were gonna go
forward with it anyway and I found this
out in October they were supposed to put
out the request for Proposal right
before Christmas sorry right before for
for for Thanksgiving and I got kind of
upset about it because there are four
hundred and seventy-five thousand
reports of abuse and neglect of kids in
California every year and the social
workers and other pupil data analysts
etcetera all the people who work in that
system who are supposed to be taking
care of those kids
haven't really had reasonable software
to work with for many years it's it's
true that the software they are using
now is out of federal compliance I'm not
sure you know what exactly that means
but I do know that we're not giving them
the tools that they need to do their
jobs given the enormity of that and the
importance of that job and so I knew
somebody in state government to call and
I called her and I said it would you
know respectfully request that you not
sign this when it comes across your desk
and she said well why not I said because
it won't work and she said do you think
we don't know that
well why would you sign it and she said
we don't have any other options well how
else do you do it and I said if we give
you another option will you consider it
and she said can you be in Sacramento on
Tuesday so we went to Sacramento and we
shared some of the ways that we've been
working at Code for America and at the
United States digital service at the VA
digital service and they said we're all
in and they took that monolithic six
hundred million dollar six-year project
and broke it up into a bunch of
different bits that a very different set
of vendors was eligible to bid on and
most importantly they said we're going
to only accept companies that want to
meet user needs not government needs
here the group of people who made that
decision were incredibly courageous
because this went against everything
that they knew how to do they threw out
several years of many people's work on
that contract and they are going at it
they're doing a fantastic job there
they're pretty far along in it right now
it's the first phase of it there is a
problem they don't have enough tech
talent and I usually end every talk by
asking people to go work in government
if you had any technical skills I'll
just do that now here but else I'm talk
a little bit about why they don't have
enough tech talent at the state of
California and everywhere else in 2012
my friend Tom Steinberg who also does
this kind of work but in the UK wrote a
blog post about a former colleague of
his who was a genius a polymath and
could have done anything at all with his
life but had chosen to dedicate his life
to public service and public sector
technology and in memorializing Chris
who had sadly died
Tom said what Chris fundamentally had
right was the understanding that you can
no longer run a country properly if the
elites don't
technology in the same way that they
grasped economics or propaganda or
ideology and his analysis and
predictions about what would happen if
the elites couldn't learn were savage
and depressingly accurate I read that in
February 2012 I read it again in October
2013 when healthcare.gov didn't work and
I was working at the White House and I
thought oh that's what he meant about
his predictions he was predicting
something like the president's signature
policy initiative go almost going down
in flames because we couldn't put up a
website but I'm thinking about that now
I I don't blame the election of Donald
Trump on bad government technology but I
do think that we you know created a
system essentially that most of the
country just wants to blow up and I'm
not really even saying I just think that
that Trump voters want to blow it up I
think a lot of the country finds a lot
of pieces of the way that we're running
things worthy of blowing up even if we
differ on exactly what and how so
there's an issue here about speed a lot
of people will say government is always
gonna run at a slower speed so if this
is Moore's law and I've borrowed these
slides from my friend clay Johnson if
government has a slight lag on it
because of a process is essentially
eventually Society will be moving this
quickly and government will be behind
but if you play that out over time it
gets worse and worse to the point where
there is such a huge difference clay
loved the the thing from Moneyball you
remember the movie about the Oakland A's
when they were terrible there were the
rich teams the poor teams 50 feet of
crap and the Oakland Athletics he was
said look we're gonna get to the point
where you've got good services you know
what's your favorite service that you
use on your mobile phone every day
services that are ok you don't love them
but you use them and then all the way
down here is going to be government
service and that's not a good that's not
a good place to be I think the issue is
if you don't use government
services a lot why should you care and
I'm I think you should care anyway a lot
of those government services are ones
connected to the safety net we spend
about 19 percent of our GDP in this
country on the safety net that's a lot
of taxpayer dollars for things that
aren't working very well if you include
basically after tax so tax deductions
tax credits you know you can't see the
square well but one of those lines is
green that's the United States were
actually the front of the pack in terms
of expenditures on social programs if
you include that so an enormous amount
of our wealth is going to that and yet I
don't need a chart to tell you that we
are not getting the outcomes that we
need we are not getting our value for
our dollar there we have people sleeping
on the street in San Francisco and
everywhere another way to look at this
is that we are spending 42 we collect
and spend about 42 billion dollars a
year in charitable contributions for the
safety net and the 11 times that through
our tax dollars so if this talk is
convincing you that government is
frustrating and you shouldn't work with
you know you shouldn't try to work
through government you should go outside
that's exactly the opposite thing of
what I'm trying to say we cannot ignore
the half trillion dollars that we are
spending on taxes I guarantee you it's
going to be easier to make that four
hundred and seventy billion dollars ten
percent more effective than it is to
double the size of charitable
contributions in this country so I want
to return to Jack Brooks because I know
you are all dying to know what happens
with Jack Brooks so I feel like there's
this or this question about whether he's
a good guy or a bad guy cuz he wrote
this law that drives me crazy but you
know I don't think that the laws that he
wrote were crazy at the time I don't
think they aged well you write a law
having to do with computer systems in
1965 it's gonna need updating that's not
that's not really a question but I
actually really love Jack Brooks what I
love about him is that he cared
about the machinery of government he got
that government should understand what's
a commodity and what you should pay a
premium for right back in the 60s and
70s
he retired in 1995 before web
applications and mobile phones and
things like that but I like to think
that if he were in Congress today he
would be the guy who would realize that
design is as important in software as it
is in buildings I would like to think
that a few around he would have updated
our procurement rules because at least
he cared right um uh sorry we're having
a little bit of a slide issue there um
he's not in government now and you guys
can't see the slides well anyway I'll
keep going um he's he's not in Congress
and we don't have somebody who advocates
for this in Congress if we did to be
honest it would be a Republican the
people who have expressed the most
concern and support for the United
States digital service has been have
been Republicans I realized I'm a Kretz
have some other stuff going on but
they've been very very vocal and helpful
those Republicans are eventually going
to want to make a law that governs how
we use technology and government again
and as you can tell I have hesitations
about writing laws that govern
technology and government but because of
what I really want are the practices of
the technology industry to show us how
to make laws that avoid that law of
unintended consequences
so I have one last story and I sorry I
realize I'm going a little bit long
there's a new law here called the
Medicare access and chip reauthorization
Act chip of course is an acronym so it's
a nested acronym and I love those
and basically it says we're gonna pay
doctors more for better quality care and
that's exactly the kind of thing that
sounds great and is gonna be hard to
implement right so we have a team at
Health and Human Services it's a branch
again of United States digital service a
woman named Mina Shane runs this and so
what Mina did is she went to the
regulators they're gonna have to write
the regulations that derive from Macra
and said here's what we're gonna do
instead of the time frame that you have
to write the regs for this law I'm gonna
ask you to give me a first version of
the regs in a fifth of the time our team
is gonna make a website that implements
those regs we're then gonna together
watch doctors use it and then you're
gonna make a revision of the regs we're
gonna make a revision of the website and
we're gonna do that five more times and
by the time they ship those regs you had
lawmakers policy makers going
this is the best regulation I have ever
written because when you when right when
regulators get to the place where
they're seeing how their stuff is
actually used they realize that
everything they've written is as my
friend Tom Lewis Moore says 500 pages of
untested assumptions so what I'm trying
to say here is that it's not so much
that we need new laws to govern
technology it's that we need better tech
practices that teach us how to make
better laws and when we can thank you
when we can do that then I'm excited to
write some laws to govern technology but
I don't think it's gonna happen in that
Deathstar way I don't think it's gonna
be the single genius who figured out
exact same language I think it's gonna
be people who recognize the messiness of
this process and realize that we don't
know how people are going to react to
things until we see them using them and
I think this is a great time to have
humility about what people think about
government and how they use it
especially after the election this
user-centered iterative and data-driven
approach is really what we're trying to
promote not just in technology but in
operations and policy making and
lawmaking and governing and it requires
that we move a lot more quickly
and that we really engage people when
you move quickly then you have to be
efficient and I do believe that
efficiency in government is a matter of
justice as a quick example of that we
worked in Atlanta in twenty thirteen or
fourteen I don't remember where we found
that people a lot of people had bench
warrants for their arrest for very
trivial things and when we did the
research we found that we were that
people were waiting on line over five
hours to pay a basic traffic ticket so
that team did this sort of little
intervention where they had the cops
hand out a site to a little piece of
paper that allows you to text your
citation number and get help by text
message so that you could skip the line
get an appointment pay online it would
remind you if you had a court date just
try to reduce the number of people who
get bench warrants for their arrest
force for silly things and the truth is
it really really matters if you get a
bench warrant because if you then make a
illegal left turn you will end up in
jail and I knew this but I tell you it
ran cold shiver up my sign when I when I
my spine when I saw this in the New York
Times after we've done this this is
bench warrants per 1000 people in cities
in Missouri in 2013 there is one there
that is 1500 bench warrants per 1000
people
that's Ferguson so this does really
matter and by the way that thing that we
did there was called court BOTS pretty
simple little text message application
there's a team in Tulsa Oklahoma that
just reimplemented that for Tulsa on
their own they're volunteers and they
decided that they needed that in Tulsa
which means that you can do this to
anybody can do this the team by the way
isn't just coders it's coders and people
who spent a year meeting people in the
Tulsa County criminal justice system and
making friends with them and figuring
how the system works a lot of non coding
experience goes into making these things
work but we are at a time right now when
a lot of us are thinking that
inefficiency and justice might be in
government might be a really good thing
so I am gonna end on just a couple of
examples of where government bureaucracy
which is driven me slightly batty over
the past six years actually is making me
quite hopeful and this is not actually
bureaucratic resistance this is the
normal and appropriate checks and
balances in our government but remember
the name remember to face Thank You US
District Judge and Donnelly who stood up
to an illegal executive order but it's
not just the normal checks and balances
that we're going to be looking at over
the next couple of years
and I in 2009 Schwarzenegger ordered his
controller to cut people's pay who
worked for the state and he just said no
and he won he never did anything they
never cut anyone's pay there was a
lawsuit John Chang won you can just say
no there's been a lot of articles about
this recently the JFK once called the
State Department a bowl full of jell-o
because it felt like it was so hard for
them to get them to do anything today I
don't know if you heard but a thousand
people who work at the State Department
wrote a letter I and a letter telling
Trump that he thought this idea was a
terrible one at the EPA in the Reagan
era they were so distraught but what
they were being asked to do that
apparently their softball league spent
more time doing anything anybody else
they said the software softball league
was more active than the actual
workplace at the EPA during the Reagan
era but the best example of this
actually comes from the simple sabotage
Field Manual that the predecessors to
the CIA put out the Strategic Services
office so this is a manual that they
published for Americans living in access
countries during the war telling them
how to slow down the operations of
companies where they might work that
might be contributing to the war effort
and I don't know if I've yeah I get a
half
these things they're hysterical when
possible refer all matters to committees
for further study and consideration make
the committee as large as possible never
less than five haggle over the precise
wording of communications minutes and
resolutions refer back to matters
decided upon at the last meeting and
attempt to reopen the question of
advisability of that decision and this
is my favorite one because I'm on stage
make speeches talk as frequently as
possible in a great length illustrate
your points by long anecdotes and
accounts of personal experience you can
find this online it is so full of great
stuff it is this the simple sabotage
annual I experienced all of these things
especially the open back
open up matters again once they've been
decided I experienced those as
friendly-fire when I worked in
government but I am just delighted that
that we can now use these things in in a
variety of different ways I would like
to remind people though of our federal
budget for a second here if you are
concerned about what our federal
government is doing and would have
concerns about working there I would
just say of course however this is what
we actually spend money on that big blue
block is Social Security the red one is
Medicaid food and nutrition assistance
housing and income support that is
mostly what our federal government does
and we need very good very smart people
to keep doing this and make sure that
these people get their money make sure
that things work in government
regardless of who is in office because
in the end of the day decisions are made
by those who show up especially the
federal at the state and local level I
always pitch again on people going into
government you if you work the stake in
local level right now you actually could
find yourself supporting the government
very much standing up for your values
and for people who need our support but
in places where they really lack the
capacity to fight in the ways that they
need to we need to
strengthen state and local government
right now and hugely when I think though
about fighting because I think that's
what a lot of the state and local
governments are going to do I think it's
really important that we think about
what we're fighting for there have been
enormous gains in the last six years
that I will very much fight to keep but
from what I've seen over the last
several years of working in government I
will say that the status quo for me is
not worth fighting for when you have 20%
of your GDP going to social services but
7,000 homeless people just here in San
Francisco when you have those 475,000
reports of abuse and neglect of kids and
we're not giving our social workers
software or data to make better
decisions when you have a housing crisis
and you don't jail the bankers but
everyone else pays that is a status quo
that isn't to me worth fighting for so I
want us to be really creative as we
enter this new era and think about what
government should do and how we should
do it I want us to fight for something
new
for something better that we haven't
seen yet I think we're just gonna have
to use a lot of that crazy energy that's
coming our way and in some cases direct
those explosions at the things that
really do need to break up and change
and in other places stand and fight for
what we have earned over the past six
years so I invite you to think about
government as an incredible force for
change even today in fact today more
than ever and thank you for being part
of this
[Applause]
it facially where to begin and we sort
of sometimes quietly judge our talks by
how much they generate questions there
are stacks and stacks of questions so
kevin has more and probably more will
come to the stage but one maybe to start
with is the idea of faceless bureaucrats
who elected officials are often sneering
at or at least when they're running for
office and there's other people who
libertarians and others oh those damn
bureaucrats simple servants when I ran
into them in when I worked for Jerry
Brown in the 70s we're pretty amazing
with the jury you've now met zillions of
them what's your perspective completely
amazing care deeply about the right
answer care deeply about serving the
public and are they they have very very
hard jobs I think some of the people
that I respect most in the world are
people who are public servants and not
just sort of we're sure telling a story
these days about people like my boss in
at the White House Todd Park who's a
serial entrepreneur very very successful
as if he is the exception you know that
something like Todd Park to come in and
do public service well I think there's
an enormous number of people like that
but even though he's he's sort of done
private sector I've been an entrepreneur
you know kind of come in and out there
are people there that have been in
public service their whole career who I
just think are absolutely gonna be the
save you know state and grace of this
country we do need to help them do their
jobs better absolutely so as the
continuity of the civil servant elected
officials come and go and then they
usually appoint you know one or two
levels into the various departments and
so on but the body of civil service is
often their career and they're there for
for decades for basically a lifetime the
service it's that kind of continuity a
good thing a bad thing how's that look
to you um it's it can be both
certainly by talking to today was
talking about it might have been
actually about how I was in in some
cases you do have people who have saved
for instance written the policy and the
policy needs to change over time but
they're protective they've been there a
while you do certainly get that that's
how it's already done or that's my
creation and I love it and I want to
protect it the kind of body is really
important though I mean I've been I've
been spending more time with the Defense
Department and the way that they rotate
people there seems to come up pretty
often as one of the biggest problems
people don't get to sort of dig in and
understand a particular problem by the
time they're learning what needs to
happen to change it they're rotated out
because of the rotation policies but the
the continuity in the civil service is
is very much a you know double-edged
sword at it's at its core though you get
people who are very good at something
that we don't eat it like new domains
that we don't really even understand and
there's not really a way to learn them
either you have to go in and sort of
apprentice to understand all these
things now some of those things probably
need to go away some of those things
need to be simplified so that they're
less of a craft but I have enormous
respect for the people who really you
know get in there and and and and learn
this I think about that today when I
heard the folks from the State
Department talking about how proud they
are to know to be the experts in and how
to protect our country then like we do
this we've been doing this for years
some of these people who are signatories
to this letter you know I've been doing
this for 15 60 years they're proud that
they have the knowledge to have this
opinion and when a politician comes in
and says that's not how we're going to
do it it's very it's deeply painful for
them because they have
pride in their work okay so what should
they do and it's really relates to
several questions that were raised from
the audience's so Spicer says well you
know if they can't get with the program
maybe they should hit the road
should they if their order should be
buckled down or should they stay quiet
and and sabotage what should they do
it's a deeply personal question it's
very relevant to me right now because
I'm in service but because so many of my
friends are asking themselves that
question mm-hmm
there is no answer there is only your
own evaluation of what's right for you I
think there are many many jobs in
government right now as I said where
you're probably not gonna get asked to
do anything terrible it's very important
that you stay because these these
functions are critical and you know in
that case you know I would certainly
encourage you to stay if you don't feel
compromised in any way if you feel like
you're you know potentially going to be
asked to do something against your
values and against your better judgment
then you have a number of options and
all of those have consequences that are
just going to be really specific and
really personal maybe entities like you
will hire them and they split from
government oh yeah principals this
reason is the question is sort of rates
of change because you made the point
about Moore's law and by the way the
same thing that's happening in
biotechnology about Devin's much moving
much faster than the regulation or
governance can keep up so Jackie asks or
actually quotes Kate Gosselin said that
all digital laws should sunset every
five years do you agree with that yeah
probably mm-hmm next date decade four
years and I mean you know part of it is
depends on what you mean you know what
well the kind of laws you were referring
to here that
that got encrusted in the 90s mm-hmm
that you know didn't know about websites
and things like that didn't know about
iteration basically those sounds like he
would like to have changed everyone to
start over yeah I think part of the
issue is that most of the laws don't
have anything to do with technology but
government technology the Privacy Act of
1972 um it governs how we think about
data privacy on the Internet in
government but it didn't anticipate the
internet simply the open wildly open to
interpretation and also not one of the
ones I talked about in the talk but in a
bit another example of something that
needs to be updated for the modern era
several people were all LD yes are there
other countries that have done this
better yeah got the apps and the tech
and so on that's really up to speed and
a shining example we could all admire
and implement that is such a great
question
and a couple of years ago I would have
answered it very very clearly that the
UK has done a fantastic job of this
really but it's it changed so they also
had a change of leadership and the
government digital service there that
did such a fantastic job of did you know
of creating better technology for for
Britain has has changed a lot since who
changed it and why
well I'll give you a bit of a history so
they had believe it or not a massive IT
government IT failure in their health
service I don't know why this is sort of
the thing some you know multi
multi-billion dollar IT project that
went bad and they had a bunch of
politicians get together around the idea
they've got to be able to do you know
digital better in the UK and they
ended up hiring this guy named Mike
Bracken who was formerly the head of
digital for the Guardian so again from
the consumer realm Mike is amazing and
he went and recruited basically all the
top talent from London to come work in
government and they had a good long run
they're not just of creating great
digital services but if sort of leading
the way they published an amazing set of
design principles that we have
essentially adopted here principles like
what well great question
so they had these 10 principles and the
first one is and you see it in my toxins
are like half of what I say is me
repeating Mike Bracken their first one
was meet user needs and then it had a
little asterisk next to it in the bottom
of the page it said user needs not
government needs and as an example of
how things have changed since the
leadership has changed in Mike had to
leave is they've deleted that little
Asterix on the page anyway they did an
amazing amount of fantastic work when I
was asked to come to DC to be part of
the Office of Science and Technology
Policy and work on this stuff what
they'd asked me to do was to help with
the program that put fellows in
different agencies and I said what we
really need to do is copy with the folks
in the UK are doing well which isn't
about innovation on the edges it's about
a central place of competence where we
can really do it right the first time
and so everything that we did at USD s
is modeled after mmm the GDS but yes
when they got new leadership the it was
an opportunity for the folks who didn't
like the change who preferred to have
what you know Mike Mike used to have a
big slide up it said no more big IT and
big IT didn't like that and it's it's
it's not it's still there but it doesn't
have the same power that it used to how
about the digital service you built
how's that doing that is doing quite
well okay is it essentially got
bipartisan support and all I could start
it has um very good bipartisan support
it turns out that when you do digital
this way in government you get better
outcomes and it's cheaper and so you
might be progressive and care about
better outcomes we're you know helping
to get more people on food stamps or
health benefits or you might care about
the fact that it's cheaper either way it
kind of sells itself and yeah it's it's
getting an enormous amount of support
and it seems to be very clearly going to
survive the transition that's fantastic
so that's a shining example UK so with
that shining example in UK's at least
partial shining example are other
entities watching all this and doing
their own versions this is a fire roll
thing out there yeah so you've got
digital services now in Australia
Argentina
I think there's simply something
somewhere in Canada they're starting one
now apparently in Germany but more
importantly they're happening at the
local level we have Ashley Myers in the
audience right now who is responsible in
large part for creating the San
Francisco digital service Roche is
another place that you could go work I'm
sorry she and many others I'm sure but I
think she did it
so we'll Martinus tell us a little bit
about Code for America how its funded
and how do you measure success what's
this sort of story so far and what's the
hope for future of both Code for America
and this whole framing that you're
bringing sir so so coach marecus started
out as a service year program so we
would put fellows in cities for a year
and they would do projects along the
lines of some of the ones I showed and
the idea really was to sort of show what
was possible with technology in the
current era and we created many many
many great projects over time what we
decided to do was to take some of those
projects that were
in one jurisdiction and those that have
potential to impact more than just one
city needed our help to do that so the
way we think about it now is our mission
is still the same so we believe that
government can work for the people by
the people in the 21st century but we
want to really show that at scale
visible at national visible scale by
really working with the government
services that help those who need the
help most
so we now only work on services for
people who need food assistance or other
kind of health who may need to not get
caught in the criminal justice system or
need access to job training so we're for
instance now taking the food stamps
application that came out of work that
we did in 2013 with the city County of
San Francisco instead of letting it go
at the end of the year and just saying
great that was a fun project we kept
iterating on iterating in the Navy
actually several products that we
developed for people on food stamps or
needing to get on food stamps and now a
couple years later let's see we haven't
running I think in nine California
counties we actually signed our contract
I think today to take it to all
California counties and we want to take
it to the rest of the country but we
want to do it not just in food stamps so
if you need food stamps you might also
need other services in Salt Lake County
this year we worked with the probation
department there to use text messaging
to keep people compliant with the terms
of your probation so texting you tell
you today's your day to go get a drug
test remember show up for court
we've got paperwork you have tech
imagers whatever it is all by text so
what we think is that if I'm texting
with you to keep you compliant with the
terms of relation why can't I also text
you and say may we apply for food
benefits on your behalf and then you
don't ever have to fill out that form
we'll fill it out for you
and submit your application we can
follow up with you by text message if
there are other questions we want to
really radically simplify how people
experience government services
that's much less about filling out forms
and much more about getting the help
that you need
[Applause]
Tech is keeps moving along and are there
sort of new capabilities with the tech I
don't know for machine learning -
amazing mobile apps that you see as the
kind of thing that should not come a
government lasts that may become the
government kind of early on and it's
that part of what Code for America is
doing is helping these various agencies
and so on not only keep current with
what finally got cool a couple years ago
but what is in the process of becoming
cool and usable and important yeah
that's a really good question and I
think the honest answer is no like we're
pretty happy with government adopting
you know the best practices of six years
ago is like that's fine I mean I think
there are places in government where you
kind of do need the latest shiny thing
but those are often in areas that you
know that are more like military
applications this is sort of not our
thing you know there's a saying amongst
government people it's like we get we're
gonna get yesterday's technology
tomorrow baby I'm not sure that
government needs to have the latest
technology I think government needs to
have basic stuff that works and it just
needs practices that yeah simple spying
with me personally how about the whole
apparatus around voting is that
something that you think needs work and
then you guys might be interested in I
definitely think it needs work I think a
lot of smart people are working on it we
are not intending to take that on
anytime soon a because I think so many
great smart people are doing it be the
social safety nets like a pretty big
thing to deal with so we've got we've
got our work cut out for us there and
then see you know originally came to the
notion that we didn't want to work on
stuff like that because we wanted to
make a
point that government is more than
politics and more than voting and that
if we started doing voting stuff ever
would just sort of put us in that bucket
of that kind of engagement I think
citizen engagement is a lot more than
voting and I think when people go to
apply for food stamps or get stuck in
the criminal justice system that is the
form of engagement and it's not a good
one yeah and and we want to work on that
so you've had a number of software
engineers should have come through your
process software InDesign and various
people and they've had this direct
experience of government then they go
back to the private secretary I guess
what's happened to them in that
experience that's a yeah that's a great
question I should start by saying that
we now hire about let's think this year
we've got nine amazing fellows working
with us so the people come in for a year
and then and then and then leave most of
our hires now are people that that are
not time-limited fellows there's just
bull time employees long-term employees
because we're actually operating these
services we need people to stay longer
but I will definitely incredibly proud
of the effect that has occurred from
having all these amazing people come in
do this year of service be exposed to
things that they wouldn't have been
supposed to and I by that I mean not
just how government works mmm
but how people who experience government
services do that so we've got two folks
in the audience right now who spent the
last year with the Seattle Police
Department and you know I enjoy it when
I get to go it's just it's when else
would you get to do that and go on
ride-alongs with the police and see what
happens to mentally ill people when they
are constantly hitting the criminal
justice system the health system they're
there get a chance to really see some of
the big problems in our country up very
very very close and for example what
happened to those two is that they
started a company to continue doing
their
I think they're the eighth company to
spin out of Code for America so that's
where some of our alumni are is actually
running companies that do this a bunch
of the other alumni are working in
government now and you know spreading
the practices and then you know others
have gone a big chunk of our alumni go
into 18f for USD s USD s is the unit
that I talked about that works in the
White House there's a sister group
called 18f that's also does federal
government technology but even if they
go back to their job like marching who
went back to to medium you know they
kind of tell us that they're forever
changed by the experience
well it sounds for like people who gonna
done jury duty and suddenly you know
haven't gone through that process ever
different feeling a much more
interesting than jury duty I have well
you know depends on it depends on the
case obviously but it is a softening of
this barrier between I think the public
and the government yeah yes part of what
you're enhancing here which is probably
a good thing yes so there's a question
mary says I am a software engineer with
Agilent we experience whether there's an
efficient way to get plucked in fixing
government plugged
I don't know heard you're a software
engineer interested in helping fix
government burrows so one place to go is
we've two job boards on our site when
it's for people that we want to hire and
I think that's coach marecus jobs but
there's also jobs Code for America org
which is jobs in local gutteral state
and local government that we think would
be amazing jobs so you can go help Peter
Kelly fix the child welfare system at
the states those jobs are on our site
you can go work in the criminal justice
system in New York City you can I mean
its technology job there's a whole a
wide range of things you can do
we consider like super high impact
really interesting jobs and you can you
can find them on our site there 18 F and
USD s jobs up there too though I think
18 FS on a hiring freeze USD s I believe
it's not but you know talk to us because
we'd love to help you start your career
in public service technology I assume
you're going to your website there's a
Avenue in for people right there or do
they have to come up here and give you
their card I'm just gonna get the URL if
this jobs dot code from her gorg
yeah so you've worked and you have
people working at various levels of
government from city to county state to
federal now say how those are different
in terms of the kinds of problems and
solutions that you've been dealing with
well um you know I think it's been
interesting because if you think about
what the federal government does most of
it does not touch citizens directly
however if you look at USDA's new 18f
they have they have taken on the parts
of government that do touch bio taxes
get health care veterans benefits um
actually a big one has been student
loans and college score cards a great
project that they did but a lot of
Technology in federal government as sort
of behind the scenes stuff that doesn't
have a citizen interface to it because
most of your interaction with government
as an individual will happen at the
local level I find people who work in
local government are just closer to
people they actually understood their
they understand people's problems in a
way that that federal government
employees tend to have their heads more
in policy than in sort of oh you know
we've got to pick up the trash we've got
to do all these things for people but
actually you know it's not just that we
sort of you know need to see this
greater fluency between the public
sector and the private sector and the
social sector we also do see a fair
amount of fluency between the levels of
government and I think that's super
healthy as well because you
if we have found in our work that you
know for the first couple of years we
didn't deal with the federal government
at all I ended up making a bunch of
connections and I work in DC in
2013-2014 and now we are much more
connected to the programs that that are
that are you know federally funded like
snap but administered locally and the
coordination between the federal
government and the states and in the
counties and then sometimes the whole
community based organization ecosystem
that helps administer them all that kind
of matters and all those people
understanding each part of that of that
sort of you know chain of money and
chain of policy is so important what do
you think is the house how is this
likely to play out give it ten years or
ten thousand years whatever time sandy
because you've now got what nine years
experience being the six years so figure
a decade of experience so far look out a
decade based on what you've seen how how
is it likely to play out is the tide
shifting in some sense of this kind of
intelligent software design approach
replacing the old over specification
vast slow no iteration approach that
used to be there is this now the future
I think it depend I would like to say
yes I certainly see evidence that it's
going that direction I think it kind of
matters whether people take it seriously
and continue to feed the talent pipeline
and whether people get involved like the
story I told a code for Tulsa
um we're never gonna be big enough to do
all the work that needs to be done so we
have to rely on people taking as
seriously as a way of changing our
country and and sort of picking it up
yeah I think it kind of depends on on
whether more people get on board I also
think that we haven't seen very much
pushback from the people who have a lot
at stake yet I I will tell you a story
about the government contracting a
system which is very positive and I will
take the names out of it but when we did
this procurement advocacy with the state
of California that's a six hundred
million dollar RFP that never went out
there were a number of companies that
were expecting that yeah to go out
instead of the state did something that
they borrowed from our friends in
federal government and 18f called and I
we're not finished with acronyms yet an
agile BPA blanket purchase agreement
where they qualify a certain they have a
whole set of vendors come and get
qualified as agile developers and the
way that brilliantly some folks at 18f
decided that they would do this is that
you can't qualify by filling out forums
you send a team and they have to do a
sprint with you sometimes it's like a
24-hour thing where they'll say here's
some data writing API and we've had some
of the most biggest names in technology
and government technology failed these
Sprint's completely like they could not
write a basic API on a set of data in 24
hours is unfortunately true so sorry if
I'm getting too technical but so a
friend of mine at the state told me a
story about a company that did not
qualify through the agile DPA that the
state did and so this public servant got
a request for a meeting from this
company and he said oh god I'm gonna get
you know they do that but like they'll
sort of you know this is terrible why
have you done this we've been working
with the state for you know for a
hundred years
and you can't do this and instead the
meeting was this guy saying we failed
that test and I wanted you to know that
we are retraining all our developers and
agile and we're gonna come back next
year and we're gonna qualify and I love
that you did this because this is gonna
make it better for us it's gonna make it
better for the state and it's gonna make
it better for the people we serve and I
just want you to know that I love this
[Music]
maybe that's a write to you but what I'm
getting from your answer is it's not a
given it's not a given and you know for
an agile government to emerge you and
everybody else has to keep paring down
there there are other government
contractors who have not been so kind to
the agenda there weren't they won the
debate goes on thank you for doing your
part in it thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]